- [Narrator] Straight people.
- Hi, I'm straight.
- [Narrator] Six are
queer, one is straight.
Our teams.
- Hi, I'm Michael.
- And I'm Zach, and we're the gay team.
- I'm Alexandra.
- And I'm Sydney.
And we're the lesbians.
- [Narrator] In a room full of liars,
can these teams find the real deal?
Each team has 15 minutes
to find the real deal.
Anytime within those 15 minutes,
a team can lock in their answer.
- I'm a little suspicious
personally of three,
just 'cause I say Converse
are a dead giveaway.
- Bisexual.
- Yeah. Okay, so six you're straight.
- Yes.
- Let's assume my twin
brother over here is a woman,
an attractive woman at that.
Give us your best pickup line.
- For me, I don't use
pickup lines at all, though,
because I feel like
they're super disingenuous.
So I like to be more genuine about it.
I really don't.
- You're an ugly girl.
- I don't use them, I don't use them.
- Okay, I have a question
for number seven.
What do you like most about women?
- Um, usually their lips.
- Okay.
- Okay, can we like eliminate someone now?
You wanna say it like twins?
- Oh, yeah, do it please.
- We're ready to make an elimination.
- [Narrator] Each team will
try to find the real deal
by eliminating the imposters.
If both teams eliminate the same person
they will be removed from the game.
- He had a nipple piercing, come on.
Come on, baby.
When you see one, you see
a gay knows another gay.
- Question for the group.
Who has like visible
tattoos out right now?
- Okay.
- Space.
- Freedom is happiness.
The universe is indifferent to our fate.
- And then the mushroom on the back.
Everyone, show us what
you got for body hair.
I wanna see your armpits
and I wanna see your legs.
- Yeah, can I see?
- Shaved, shaved...
Shaved.
All shaved?
- Okay.
- Last question for the
group and this one can be
a little trigger warning.
How do you feel about the word (bleep)?
Should queer people be able to say it,
or do you not think so?
So personally, I've reclaimed
the F word completely.
I use it in my regular vernacular
- And it's a big conversation
in the queer community--
- 'Cause Alex doesn't like it.
- If we can use it.
I don't like it, like I'm still,
like hella uncomfortable with it.
- I don't use the word,
I don't condone the word.
- Okay, how do you feel about the word?
Should queer people be able to use it?
- I don't know, I guess
it's not really my business.
- Word, three?
- I don't say it.
- I feel like if the
word goes to your group,
it's like women saying
(bleep), it's the same thing.
So like yeah, you can say it.
- You can't say it.
- Yeah, I can't, but
they can say it, yeah.
- Word, number six.
- Um, there's a few words
that I don't think that
anyone should be using.
That's one of them, honestly.
- Word, all right, and seven?
- Yeah, I agree, it's a bad word, just...
- I use (bleep) all the time.
- I love the word (bleep).
- I will say....
- All right, we're ready to vote.
- We're ready to make an elimination.
- [Narrator] As a reminder,
if both teams eliminate
the same person,
that person will be removed from the game.
- She had a mushroom tattoo
with glitter around it.
- It's like I eat (pussy).
- You eatin' (bleep), like on the reg.
100%.
- Okay, who here in the group,
show of hands, played
a sport in high school?
- I played basketball.
(laughter)
- I played volleyball.
- Four years of soccer.
- No one said softball,
so I was like (laughs),
I was really hoping
that'd be a dead giveaway.
- Number two, iced or hot coffee?
- Um, I think I like hot coffee best.
- Okay, a little sus.
- Another question for the whole group.
If you were at the bar,
what drink would you order?
- I would get a water or soda.
I don't drink, really.
- Okay.
- Oh, I've never been to a bar
'cause I don't drink, sorry.
- Do you guys do everything straight?
- Three?
- I'm 19.
- You're 19?
- I drink tequila, sodas, or margaritas.
- Proud of you, okay.
- I'm rum and coke.
- Beer for me.
- Beer?
- Golden Rogue, all day.
- Six, get out. We know.
- Mine's just tequila
shaken with ice and lime.
- Lesbians, what do you order at a bar?
- Espresso martini, wherever I'm at.
- Numbers two, four, three, and one.
Do you find my brother
typically attractive?
- Uh, not really.
- Gay. Go on number two, I'm just kidding.
- No, I think you're cute.
- Okay. Three?
- Yeah, I think he's cute.
- Yeah, you have a really good jaw line.
- Oh, we're gonna make
another elimination.
Queer aura, you can tell.
And the glitter on the eyes, come on.
- Gay. All day.
- Um, we have a challenge for the group.
One and two, please gaze
into each other's eyes
and hold hands.
So there's straight panic,
and then there's gay panic.
Like, I am very good friends with Alex.
I don't wanna stare at her
in the face for 15 seconds.
- My hands are really clammy.
- I know, it's pure panic, let's go.
- Here? Okay.
- Yeah. Okay, now share your favorite
straight sex position with each other.
- My mom's, I might watch this.
I don't know, that's
awkward, that's really, um...
- Come on, they're all super vanilla.
- You get one option.
- I like doggystyle, I guess.
- Whoa.
Um, okay.
- I don't really have a
favorite sex position.
- (bleep) I should have said that.
- We'll go with three and four now.
Share your favorite sex position.
- Mine's with my legs on his shoulders.
- I don't have one.
- All right, now the throuple.
Hold hands please.
This one's a little bit different.
When did you know you were straight?
How are you, just like gay is not for me?
You're just like, I
was, I'm born this way?
- Yeah.
- Six?
- Um, I'm probably gonna
say when high school sports
and the experimenting
happened with all those people
going through it, and I was
like, this ain't for me.
When you start playing around, honestly.
- Okay.
- Kinda put me off.
- And seven.
- I guess when I had my first girlfriend.
That was kind of the giveaway.
- What age?
- Nine.
- Nine. Hmm.
- That's an early age.
- Okay, we're done with the boys.
We're ready to eliminate someone.
- Go ahead Michael.
- Okay, this one's for five and six.
What do you guys both
like about being straight?
- I don't go like, oh,
I like it, I'm just...
- Never been asked that before.
What do I like about being straight?
What is there to like about it?
- Oh, you tell me.
- Amen.
(laughter)
I have no clue.
- I don't really know.
- It's a lifestyle like
everybody else, right?
- I don't know about that.
Straight turf.
Really hard out here.
- Really something.
I think we're ready to lock in.
- We, we know our lock in, yeah.
- Right, right, right?
- Right? Okay.
- Okay, this is a group question.
What's your relationship
like with both your parents?
- So my mom, she's more
like traditional Hispanic
so she's not like super like affectionate,
but we have a good
relationship, whereas like,
I know she loves me.
Father, I don't have a dad so
I don't have a relationship with my dad.
- All right, number two.
- Yeah. I love my mom very much.
I love my dad very much, and
I think they did their best
raising me, me and my siblings.
So that's something that I
aspire to be as a parent one day.
- Love that.
- I wish that we could...
- I have a good relationship with my mom,
and I, I don't have a
relationship with my dad.
- Moms so far, obviously.
- Good relationship with my parents.
I mean my dad, he wasn't
very like forceful
like a lot of dads was.
He was just like very laid back.
He was very like open with
his emotions and stuff.
Not really like be tough and all that.
- Father is not in this
country, so for a long time.
Don't really know.
Mother, great. I mean, I talk
to her once a week at least.
- Who gave you those eyes?
- From my father's side, I believe.
- Okay. We wanna eliminate someone.
- [Narrator] Person number
two, unfortunately our teams
do not think you are the real deal,
and we will ask you to
step off the platform.
- See you later.
We love you, sorry.
- Look at her go, though.
- Killin' it.
- Surprise.
- Okay, this is for the group
of straight people here.
Can you raise your hand
if you have Co-Star?
- Do you have the app on your phone?
Yeah, you do. Yeah, you do.
(laughter)
- Okay. And what is your
relationship with the Lord?
What's your, um--
- Or a Lord?
- Yeah, what is your
religious affiliation, if any?
Number one.
- I am a non-practicing Catholic.
- Non-practicing Catholic.
Number three?
- Agnostic.
- I'm spiritual.
- Yeah, same thing.
Used to be atheist, now I'm agnostic.
- I grew up in the Baptist church,
but I no longer, um, attend.
- Me too, buddy.
- Grew up as a practicing Catholic,
but then kind of got busy
and not so much but...
- Mhm, got busy.
Do we do it?
- Um, yeah I think we know.
I think we're ready to lock it in.
- [Narrator] Sydney and
Alex, you decided to
lock in your real deal,
so the game is done.
- If I'm wrong...
- It's over.
- I'm gonna cry.
I swear to God, I'm so sure.
- Okay, we think the straight
person is person number five.
When we were doing the questions
you have a very, this is ugly,
but like a straight demeanor.
- Yeah. Your voice is
really deep and that's a,
that's a dead giveaway from me.
I'm like, I don't hear a
lisp, I don't hear anything.
Kinda straight.
- The hat.
You just have straight vibes.
- Okay.
- We chose number seven as our real deal.
You're just like undeniably chiseled.
You look like someone who might struggle
with people assuming you're queer,
but that like, you're actually straight.
You just love investing in yourself.
- [Narrator] For those
of you who have not been
chosen by our teams, you
can step off the platform.
- Get out, gays, get out.
- Have fun at Pride.
- Get out, get out.
- Like, what?
- See you at the bars.
- My anxiety is through the roof.
- I know.
- Let's do this.
- [Narrator] If the lights
on your podium turn green,
that means you have chosen the real deal.
If they turn red, that means
you have chosen an imposter.
Michael and Zach, because you
locked in your answer first,
we're gonna reveal the answer to you.
- Oh...
- Are you kidding me?
- A double eyebrow slit.
- [Narrator] Alex and
Sydney, you have chosen
straight person number seven.
- Damn it!
- Obviously, that was a dead, no offense--
Look his tits are showing!
It was three. It was (bleep) three.
- [Narrator] Because you
both were not able to
find the real deal, we'll
have them reveal themselves
to you.
- Yep, yep, that's my guess.
- [Narrator] Can the real straight person
please reveal themselves in 3,
2,
- Shut up! No!
- You played basketball!
- Dude!
- No!
- That is so reckless.
- We had a discussion
earlier like, oh the hair.
- Yeah. I was like, for sure.
- What's wrong with my hair?
What's wrong with my hair?
I feel like I get it a
lot that people think I'm
a lesbian because I feel like I'm not like
presenting super feminine.
But I mean, what is feminine?
In my opinion, I am a female
and whatever I do is feminine.
- A lot of it is like your expression.
If you're lucky enough to choose
what you put on your body,
you are usually using that
as a sign for other
people in the community.
She was probably like
one of my last choices,
so I was like, fuck.
- We, we were talking about it,
'cause we thought one
could potentially be it,
but like the energy that she
was giving off, I'm like,
she could just be bi.
- Oh no, I'm still fuckin' pissed.